DANIEL SIEBERG: Hi there.
I'm Daniel Sieberg, and you're
watching I/O Live.
We're here at Google I/O , and
we're going to be showcasing
content from different partners,
from Googlers.
Of course, giving you tours of
all the sandboxes here at
Moscone Center over the
next couple of days.
And truth be told, we're
actually here before the doors
opened in Androidville, and
we're going to start out by
talking to Andrew from
Crittercism.
So, Andrew, tell me, what
is Crittercism?
I'm a little worried about
some of these creatures
coming after me.
What does it mean to monitor
apps and get that real time
information for a lot
of developers?
ANDREW LEVY: Sure, yeah.
So, we are a cross-platform
crash reporting and error
analysis tool for mobile
app developers.
In a broader sense, we help
them find performance
bottlenecks.
The story is that there's a lot
of great testing companies
here today, but the fact is,
the mobile ecosystem,
especially Android, is moving
so quickly that really, you
need a diagnostic tool to help
you once you release your
application.
And that's really
what we provide.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah, let's go
through a spin here, if you
can give us a demo.
ANDREW LEVY: We can jump
right in, here.
So, this is when a developer
integrates our SDK, it takes
less than five minutes
to get started.
They see this page, and this is
all their crashes that have
occurred over time.
So we're essentially
a big data company.
We're crunching all this data
and helping tell you what are
the most critical problems
affecting your user base.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And this is an
overarching look at what's
going on, but you can
even drill down to
a particular user?
ANDREW LEVY: Yeah, and so the
data gets extremely granular.
So, these are all issues.
You can drill down to a
particular problem.
We give the engineers a look
in the stack trace.
If there's a localization issue,
they can quickly drill
in where on the map.
We also provide some
diagnostics.
So, the idea here is we help
recreate what the average user
looks like at the time when
they had a problem.
So if it was a member
leak, you'd see this
skewed to the right.
If they ran out of disk space,
you'd quickly see that.
If it was a device-specific
problem or an OS-specific
issue, it would quickly
become apparent here.
And the idea is that we help
you recreate the issue
internally and quickly
push out a fix.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And earlier,
you were showing me what
looked like a heart rate monitor
view of what's going
on with different users.
What's that all about?
ANDREW LEVY: Yeah.
So, everything we do
is in real time.
So, these are app loads and
crashes as they come in.
So often, teams will
have this up on a
monitor as they release.
And of course, they hope that
the error line right here is
flatlining, but issues,
or critters, do
creep out in the wild.
In addition to that, we help the
manager of the team look
at a high level and how they're
doing over time.
And so, on each successive
release, we give you an idea
if you're getting better
at fixing those bugs.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Great.
So this is all feedback that can
be used and shared across
the different teams.
This is not just isolated
to one person who
can see this view.
Anyone can get a quick
snapshot of all this.
ANDREW LEVY: Yeah.
It's a collaborative effort by
your engineering team, so they
can go in, they can comment on
these issues, they can close
bugs, they can drill down--
DANIEL SIEBERG: Prioritize,
right?
Based on the sheer volume of
responses that you're getting?
ANDREW LEVY: Yeah.
You can imagine needing to
sort your crashes or your
errors by the number
of users affected.
You imagine fixing the top 10,
and that's easily 75% of your
bugs gone right there.
And it also ties into your
workflow, so there's support
integration where if you get
an email from a user
complaining, you can look them
up in our system and figure
out exactly what problems
they're having.
And of course, integrations into
your bug tracking systems
and whatnot.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Any quick
advice for anyone who's
developing on the Android
platform and how
this could help them?
ANDREW LEVY: Well,
we did some early
analysis that showed that--
I mean, it's pretty common, but
null pointer exceptions
and out of memory are the
top two issues that
we typically see.
And so, make sure you pay
attention to your application
life cycle changes, and stop
allocating so many bitmaps.
[LAUGHTER]
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right,
good advice.
Andrew from Crittercism,
thank you so much.
And do you pay these guys?
Are they your employees?
ANDREW LEVY: Yeah, They seem
to follow us around
everywhere.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Thank you.
ANDREW LEVY: Thanks.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Man,
I am winded.
Androidville's a big place.
I don't know if you
noticed that.
We're here with Pebble and Eric
to talk about what Pebble
is, but also, of course, about
how Android ties in, and
developers who are creating
some cool
stuff for this watch.
So talk us through what Pebble
is, and we'll get to why
running's tied into
this as well.
ERIC MIGICOVSKY: So, Pebble's a
smart watch that talks your
cell phone.
You can do things, normal watch
things, like look at the
time, and stop watch, and
that kind of stuff.
But the really cool thing about
Pebble is that you can
write apps for the watch and
integrate Pebble with apps
that run on your
Android phone.
So we're today launching an
SDK that enables Andrew
developers to push intents
to our app that get
forwarded to watch.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's
very cool.
So it's a watch that's a
platform as well, in a sense,
and you've partnered with
RunKeeper to talk about one
here today that a lot of people
who are jogging and
runners would appreciate,
because you get that
at-a-glance, sort of, a use with
your watch rather than
having to pull out your phone.
ERIC MIGICOVSKY: Yeah.
So, RunKeeper's the first app
that we've integrated with,
and we were just chatting with
their developer this week.
He was able to integrate
RunKeeper with Pebble
in about one hour.
So, what that meant was he
added features that were
unavailable to RunKeeper
users before.
And using pebble, yeah, it just
makes its own app that
much better.
So, one of the really cool
things you can do is, if
you're going for a run--
normally when you're going for
run with RunKeeper, you've got
your phone going, GPS connected,
in your pocket.
But if you're, say, stopped, you
see a friend on the street
or something like that, and
you chat for a moment, you
have to press the pause button
in the app or it auto-detects
it after a little while.
But with Pebble, if you want to
pause, you can just pause
it, and then when you want to
start your activity again, you
can just click the button
here, and--
[PEBBLE WATCH - "Activity
resumed."]
ERIC MIGICOVSKY: -- and it
starts your run again.
The cool thing about Pebble and
RunKeeper together is that
instead of having to look at
your phone to see your stats,
like your distance traveled,
your laps time, or your pace,
you can just look down to your
watch and see all the details
on your watch.
It's kind of like a heads-up
display for the app.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Any advice you
would give to developers who
are really excited about doing
something for Pebble, whether
it's something related to
sports, or activities, or just
getting through life without
having to pull out your phone
all the time?
What sort of things
are you looking at
coming down the pike?
ERIC MIGICOVSKY: Well, I think
at the beginning, Pebble's
going to be really useful
for sports and fitness
applications.
That heads-up display is
going to be great.
I can imagine going for a day on
the mountain, like skiing,
with Pebble.
Instead of having to take my
phone out on the chair lift to
see who's called or who's sent
me an email, I can just look
down to my watch and see that,
and then at same time, see how
fast I've been going.
Other things that are great with
Pebble are notifications.
So, what we really want to
encourage people to do is use
Pebble as well as the
notification bar.
So if your app spits out
notifications that pop up on
the top notification shade,
you can also register an
intent that will send that
notification to the watch.
So, imagine if you're writing an
IM client, or stock market
app, or weather app, or any sort
of local check-in app, it
would be great to be able to get
those notifications right
on your wrist.
The user can feel the vibration
from the watch and
instantly see what's going
on without even
pulling up their phone.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Tell me a little
bit about the history
of Pebble for folks
who don't know.
You got your start, in a
sense, on Kickstarter.
Huge response, coming out when,
what sort of interest
have you seen since you
announced this?
ERIC MIGICOVSKY: Yeah.
So, we've been working on
watches for a little while
now, but we launched Pebble,
our latest watch, on
Kickstarter a couple
months ago.
In about one month, we sold
over 85,000 watches.
And the Pebble watches will
start coming out in the fall,
and users will start downloading
apps for Pebble
watches right around then.
So, we're opening our SDK out.
Actually, today we're launching
the Android SDK, and
more portions of the SDK will
come out over the summer.
People will be able to write
their own watch faces that
actually run right
on the watch.
But today's the first time that
we're talking about the
intent-based API, which allows
Android developers to push
intents to the watch.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Any other sort
of advice you would give to
developers who were curious
about doing
something with this?
ERIC MIGICOVSKY: We're going
to have an emulator out in
August, so not only could you
start developing before the
watch comes out, but you'll
actually be able to see what
your app will look like when
you push things to
the watch, in August.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Very cool.
Are you wearing this all the
time, pretty much, now?
ERIC MIGICOVSKY: 24/7, yeah.
That's cool.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Great.
Eric, thank you so much.
And I've got watch envy
at the moment.
I feel like I've got
to get hold of one.
How can people get one if
they want one still?
ERIC MIGICOVSKY: If you go to
getpebble.com, you can get in
line for picking up a watch.
And if you're a developer,
you can to go
developer.getpebble.com
to check it out.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Great.
Thank you so much.
And I've got to run off now.
All right.
We have flown over here now to
talk to Hipmunk, and Ryan, who
works at Hipmunk.
He's going to talk to
us about-- sorry.
These guys aren't even
paying attention.
All right.
This will be take three.
We have flown over here to talk
to Ryan from Hipmunk,
Hipmunk being a travel
app, helps you
find flights and hotels.
And Ryan, we're going to give
folks a little demo of how it
works, but also, of course,
talk about the
experience with Android.
So maybe walk us through the
idea of the agony ranking.
RYAN OLDENBURG: Sure.
So, we at Hipmunk
consider it--
a kind of point for a lot of
people is travel planning,
especially on a phone,
because phones are a
very unique form factor.
And getting a lot of information
in a small space
is really difficult,
so it's something
we took pretty seriously.
One of the first things we
worked on was flight search,
which we took a lot of time
to make look good.
So basically, to do a search,
you enter your city,
destination, dates, all
the standard stuff.
Then once you've run a search,
you'll get to a result set
that looks like this.
And this is probably
different than
anything you've seen before.
What we lay out are the flight
in a bar that shows you how
long it is, whether or not
there's a layover, and
who's flying it.
In specific, we do a thing
called "sorting by agony,"
which is to say that we don't
strictly sort by price,
because we consider your
time worth something.
So if you'll notice here, we
have a nonstop Delta flight
for $423, which is actually
above a US Airways, which is
less expensive, but both longer
and has a layover.
So we're kind of saying, it's
not that much more expensive
for how much time you're saving,
which in this case is
over three hours.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's a good
point, that you could save
$100, but then you have a
layover for four hours, and
you end up hating yourself
for agreeing to that.
RYAN OLDENBURG: Exactly.
Travel is agonizing.
You just want to get to your
destination in as good a mood
as possible, right?
So, that's what agony is
designed to help you with.
But if you want to just see by
price, we're not going to let
you not do that.
We show by price.
You can see the least
expensive first.
And then, once you've selected
your flights, you can just go
ahead and book through
the app.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And it will
actually tie in your calendar,
too, if there are particular
dates that you need to
remember when you're
booking a flight.
RYAN OLDENBURG: Yeah,
yeah, exactly.
So one of the things we added
very recently was what we call
calendar integration.
So, often when you're planning
a trip, you'll have things on
your calendar you're traveling
for or events that you need to
avoid when you're picking a
flight, maybe an appointment
or something.
And so, what we'll do is
actually show those things
that are on your calendar
on the timeline, here.
So you can know, well, maybe
that morning flight isn't a
great idea because I need to
be somewhere until 10:00 or
something like that.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
So you've helped us
with our flights.
Now we need to figure out the
hotel accommodations.
How does that work?
RYAN OLDENBURG: Well, you just
go over to a hotel search, and
the first thing we do is let
you pick your location, or
just do My Location, which is
pretty much always the case.
You're just looking for
a hotel nearby.
So if we just do one for tonight
for one guest, we just
hit Search, and as the hotels
load in here, they start to
place themselves on the map.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Using Google
Maps, of course.
RYAN OLDENBURG: Yep, using
Google Maps, of course.
And we actually had a lot of
fun working with this on
Android in specific.
The Google Maps SDK really
allowed us to do a lot of the
map stuff without really even
having to worry about it.
Just kind of took care
of it for us.
So it was nice to have Google
helping us out with something
that really is technically
challenging.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
So it looks like a bunch of
them have loaded in here.
RYAN OLDENBURG: Yep.
The search just finished.
So on the map, you'll see
these gray pips and then
colored pips.
So what we've done there is
we've shown where all the
hotels are and attempted to
suggest some of the ones that
would be the best value
for you, and those
are the colored pips.
So if you pick on one of them,
you can see what the hotel's
called, a little picture
of it, price, rating.
And you can pop around, see
if one's more interesting.
Now, along with that calendar
integration, if you have an
event that you're coming to,
for example, San Francisco
for, we'll put a little pip on
the map that shows where that
event is so that you can know
what hotels are nearby.
And then another thing we do,
which is pretty cool, is if
you haven't maybe been to a city
before, we do have what
are called heat maps, which
hopefully the Wi-Fi will load
in here pretty quick.
But often, you don't really know
where you want to be in a
city, but what the heat maps do
is show you, well, here's
where all the food is.
Maybe you're a foodie, you want
to know where the best
restaurants are.
This will help you with
that suggestion.
The warmer it is, the more
likely some good food is going
to be nearby.
Little things like that help
make the hotel such a lot
easier on a phone where you
don't really have room to go
and open a bunch of tabs,
learn about the city.
You just need to know
where to stay real
quickly and get it done.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Yeah,
make it efficient.
All right.
Just quickly, any sort of
learnings you can pass on to
other Android developers, and
something you maybe take away
from the experience?
RYAN OLDENBURG: Yeah, sure.
So, I've worked on Android a
couple years, and the biggest
thing I've learned is often when
I face a problem, I want
to solve it with the tools
I already know.
But there's truly often a way
that Android is trying to get
you to use that they've built
into the system and made
really robust.
So, don't be afraid to take a
second and learn what Android
is suggesting you use,
because it'll pay for
itself in the long run.
It'll work with newer systems,
it'll look better as they
update the OS itself, and
instead of you aging without
the system, you get to
keep up for free.
And people will feel more
natural using your app,
because you're using things
that they're used to.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And less
stressed, which is what
Hipmunk is all about,
less-stress travel.
All right, Ryan.
Safe travels as you're
on the go.
We appreciate it.
RYAN OLDENBURG: Yeah,
definitely.
It's been fun.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Photo sharing,
social, and Wi-Fi Direct.
These are all things that are
part of Ekata Systems.
And I'm joined now by Alan to
talk about what that all
means, and with Android, of
course, in particular.
And your shirt says "Tapestry."
Tell me what
that's all about.
ALAN TSAI: Yes, thank
you, Daniel.
So, Ekata Systems, we aim to
make the mobile social
experience more personal and
more engaging by facilitating
interactions in the
physical world.
So, our first application, the
first incarnation of our
vision, is an app called
Tapestry, which is essentially
a proximity-based photo
show-and-tell application.
It allows you to share photos
with people who are close to
you, with the word "close" being
a double entendre, close
being people that you care
about, your friends and
family, and close from a
proximity distance standpoint.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So you can
choose who those people are
within your network.
ALAN TSAI: Absolutely.
You get to curate your photos
and curate the people that you
want to share those
photos with.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
Can you run us through
a little demo?
ALAN TSAI: Sure.
So, the demo's actually running
on ICS, but the
product will only launch on
Jelly Bean, so you'll see some
minor differences and tweaks.
But we'll go ahead and run
through these right now.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So these are as
though we're sharing with
these different devices here?
ALAN TSAI: Exactly.
DANIEL SIEBERG: But I could
be anywhere within how
much space right now?
ALAN TSAI: Within 20 to 30
meters, but the idea of the
sharing, again, is the
experience we're after is
people huddling around.
For example, let's say everybody
goes to a concert.
Everybody perceives the night
from their own perspective,
from their own vision,
from their own lens.
And at the end the day, we're
all at 3:00 AM at the coffee
shop, and we're going through
pictures, and this is the
experience we're trying
to create.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So instead of
all huddling around one phone,
and hey, look at this--
ALAN TSAI: That's right.
Now they have their own
devices they can--
DANIEL SIEBERG: Absolutely, with
some interesting twists
to that experience.
So, let's say, if here, we'll
pick a couple photos.
Speaking of concerts, let's say
we all went to a concert.
DANIEL SIEBERG: You're
choosing the photos
there, right now?
ALAN TSAI: Exactly.
You're picking the photos, and
you hit a button-- that's the
curate button--
and in this version, it is
asking you to turn on Wi-Fi
Direct, but in Jelly Bean, it'll
go straight to the app.
So, another reason to upgrade
to Jelly Bean.
So, as soon as that's
turned on--
so right now, this phone is
broadcasting within the 20, 30
meter radius that you're
showing a slide show.
Now, these are the folks, here--
you might not be able
to see on the screen--
these folks will--
DANIEL SIEBERG: They're
receiving this
slide show, in a sense.
They're experiencing it.
You're driving the vehicle or
the slide show, in a sense,
and they're participating.
ALAN TSAI: Absolutely.
So they discover your slide
show, and as soon as they find
you, they'll click on you, and
you should get a request
saying someone's trying to
join your slide show.
You accept that, and the other
members join as well.
Let's see if this
goes through.
Here it is, I'm sorry.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
So we can see that it started
off here, on this device.
ALAN TSAI: Let's see if
that goes through.
There it is.
So you see, all screens have the
photo, and as you scroll
through, everybody's image
moves in synchronicity.
If there's a photo that you
like, that you don't have on
your device, you simply
swipe down.
Maybe we switch the--
see if we can see on the
other side, here.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So you can
actually share the photos as
well as show them to people?
ALAN TSAI: Absolutely.
So if this comes up, let's
see-- it does.
So as you see, what we see on
screen here is a client.
When you swipe down, you'll
see the image is saved
directly, peer-to-peer,
from device to device.
Not a single bit goes over the
2G, 3G, 4G, Wi-Fi, Bluetooth,
whatever it is.
It goes directly peer-to-peer,
from one device to another.
And going back to the idea of
the experience, if you pinch
to zoom, all the devices--
DANIEL SIEBERG: They'll get
the same experience.
ALAN TSAI: Exactly right,
exactly right.
DANIEL SIEBERG: This is
really cool stuff.
I mean, any learnings
from this?
Any takeaways for folks who are
developing on Android do
you want to share?
ALAN TSAI: Absolutely.
Essentially for us, Wi-Fi Direct
is available for the
very first time, and
only in Android.
So, I think it really speaks to
the vision of Android, who
realized that technology as it
evolves should not just be
more powerful, but also
more personal.
And I think with a
proximity-based sensor using
Wi-Fi, I think it facilitates
a new type of interaction
between people.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And how can
folks get hold of this if they
want to try it out?
ALAN TSAI: We'll be going
live tomorrow.
DANIEL SIEBERG: OK.
Al, this is really cool stuff.
Thank you so much.
From Ekata Systems, Tapestry.
Be on the lookout for it.
ALAN TSAI: Thank you, Daniel.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Appreciate it.
OK.
If you've ever had the
experience of having, let's
say, 20 or 30 tabs open in your
browser, or trying to
remember to read something or
view something later, well,
Pocket is to the rescue.
Nate is with Pocket, the
founder of Pocket.
It used to be called
Read It Later.
So, tell me about it, and was
that description accurate?
NATE WEINER: Absolutely, yeah.
As you said, the problem is that
we're running into great
content all day long, and the
issue ends up being that, as
you said, like you're emailing
yourself links, you have a
billion tabs open in your
browser, but ultimately the
time that you discover that
content is not necessarily the
time that you want to view it,
or even really the best place
or the best device
to view it on.
And that's why there's Pocket.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So Pocket's
helping us with that
information overload, in
a sense, to organize
and save it for later.
NATE WEINER: Exactly.
So instead of trying to remember
where you found that
article or that video, or
anything else you run across
online, you can simply just put
it in Pocket, and it will
be in one place, accessible
from anywhere.
DANIEL SIEBERG: All right.
Well, let's have a look at this
sort of digital pocket
that you can put it
into, in a sense.
Now, you've got a laptop here.
We've got a couple of
Android devices.
Tell me about how a website
can get saved into Pocket.
NATE WEINER: Sure.
So for example, if I'm on my
computer, and I come across
some article that looks
interesting to me, I can
simply just save
that to Pocket.
And in this case, I'm using
our Chrome extension.
It's just a one click
save to Pocket.
You can save articles,
you can save video,
you can save anything.
So for example, also here, I
can save a YouTube video.
And so, whenever I'm actually
ready to view that content--
so for example, if I'm
on my commute on
the way in to work--
I can just simply pick up my
phone, and all that content
that I just saved is here.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And does it
save it chronologically?
Is that how it comes
into your device?
NATE WEINER: You can order it
different ways, but generally,
newest is at the top and
it flows through.
So for example, this article
that I just saved here is now
on the device, and we formatted
it in this really
great, easy to view article
layout, as you can see.
And it just synced right to the
phone without really me
having to do anything.
DANIEL SIEBERG: So that's
a good point.
So, it used to be called Read
It Later, but you might want
to view something later,
shop somewhere later.
There are lots of iterations of
what you want to do later.
NATE WEINER: Exactly.
So, you can very easily
switch between
different content modes.
So for example, if I just want
to see my videos, I can just
switch, and now all the videos,
and that YouTube video
that I just saved, is easy
to find as well.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Now, we've
got an Android tablet.
Same sort of an experience.
What was it like developing to
get all this content across
different devices, and that
experience of consuming it
differently?
NATE WEINER: So, Android's made
that really easy for us
for a number of reasons.
So for example, the articles
and stuff I saved, they've
already synced to my
tablet as well.
If I have other devices or other
platforms, that's all in
sync immediately.
But Android, between a phone,
which is a small form factor,
and a big tablet form factor,
they've made things very easy
to move between those
different sizes.
The flexible layouts
and everything
have been really great.
But the best thing that we have
on Android is actually,
as I was just describing, the
fact that all this stuff
happened instantly.
That's something we can only
do on Android, even though
we're on other platforms as
well, is using C2DM, the
cloud-to-device messaging
system.
So essentially, the second I
hit Save To Pocket on the
computer, it messaged out to
all the devices to get that
content download and have it
ready to go, so that when
you're on the subway, even if
you don't have Wi-Fi, you can
actually view it.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's great.
So, just finally, you want to
show us what it looks like on
the sample here?
NATE WEINER: Yeah, sure.
So, very similar layout,
but optimized
certainly for a tablet.
And again, I think what I use
tablets most for is viewing
videos, so I'd love to be able
to just open up the video
section, and just find something
to watch, and just
kick back on the couch and watch
videos, which is great
for a tablet.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Any advice or
learnings that you had with
the Android development
experience you want to share
with folks?
NATE WEINER: Yeah, so for
us, we certainly had an
interesting perspective, because
we are on so many
other platforms in addition
to Android.
And I'd say our biggest advice
is always if you're going to
build an Android app, build
an Android app.
If you look at our apps on other
platforms, we all really
respect the conventions of
each of those platforms.
And if you look at what Pocket
looks like on Android versus
on our website, or versus on our
iOS devices, we've made it
look like an Android app and
work really well as an Android
experience.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Cool.
Well, Nate, thank you so much
for that demo from Pocket.
And speaking of later, stay
tuned for much more later here
on I/O Live.
I'm Daniel Sieberg.
Stay tuned.